anger is a legitimate response in the
face of Injustice ladies and gentlemen
totally fine get mad get mad at me I
don't give a [__] get mad then go do
something about it to fix the
problem you know I think I think
shaming um you know for my generation
was
normalized they would broke shame you um
you know if you're
driving if you're driving a shitty car
or motorcycle and they had better car or
motorcycle they would broke shame you
nice car buddy it's cool you know but
it's not a German car then you go and
get a German car oh nice car buddy it's
not an Italian car it's not a Lambo or
Ferrari or McLaren or British sports car
and they kind of go from there right
shaming actually works it it it actually
motivated My Generation to do something
with themselves right uh fat shaming
Works a good friend of mine at one of
our Retreats last year uh showed up in U
bre and ridge we were doing some skiing
and uh you know we're in the kitchen I
could see was like out of shape I'm like
dude like you're shaped like a pear he
he was he was talking about not being
able to do certain things and I'm like
it's because you're shaped like a pear
like you're like you're skinny fat and
calling him skinny fat got him motivated
to fix that in less than six
months what else Works fat shaming Works
broke shaming Works [__] shaming worked
you know um grandmothers
great-grandmothers would do it to their
kids their granddaughters for years but
shaming has been removed from the fabric
of society because it because it hurts
people now it hurts his feelings like I
said get hurt get mad and then go do
something about
it the only reason why you get mad when
somebody calls you out and says hey you
know you're shaped like a pear is
because you're shaped like a pear if
somebody said to me hey Rich you're
shaped like a peir I'd be like
you might want to check the prescription
on your glasses bro right because it
doesn't bother anybody if it's not true
it only bothers you if it's
true anyway the use of prawn or other
outlets as substitute for relationships
they don't form tribes with good men
that are good at being men that's
something else I've been I've been
banging on about for ages and ages guys
you know I have my own Community you can
learn more about it on I gotta [__]
it's backwards here you can learn more
about it on my website okay
it's for Killers it's for guys that are
doing something with their lives it's
for guys that are putting a dent in the
universe that that have already leveled
themselves up it's not for noobs okay if
you're a noob go to the gym lift the
weights make the money be captivating do
something interesting with your
life my group is not a starter group it
is not a
101 it's not a build a better beta but
that's what Society wants they want to
build better betas right I want strong
virtuous men I want men that are good
men and also good at being
men I want men that aren't little
[__] or [__] um I want guys that
are strong and virtuous and have
competency skills that are useful to the
group your network is your net worth but
guys are avoiding the opportunity to go
and do any kind of work to to put
themselves in rooms you know I'll say
you know I did a video on the
entrepreneurs and cars Channel
somebody's you know messag me the
requests of what you know what would you
do with $5,000 how would you invest
$5,000 I've got $5,000 Rich what do I do
with it what do you think I should do to
invest with it and you'd be surprised at
the comments and reaction of that video
because I'm because I'm saying things
like invest in
yourself if your professional interests
are dentist indry if your professional
interests are entrepreneurship if your
professional interests are being an
arborous I don't care whatever it
happens to be whatever is it that you
know you want to be world class at then
spend time and money on developing
yourself and those skills so that you
can become a weapon in your own life and
make some serious money and have impact
and develop a strong Network and aren't
guys complaining oh you just want to
sell your cor you want
to so when did I even say any of that in
the video but they they they will
automatically regulate themselves to I'm
a
victim bald man with beard
bad let's say bad
things like I said get mad if I say
something that pisses you off good good
get mad get mad at me I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out